what's next for you
because obviously you know you could
pretty much do whatever you want at this
point but like what is like on your like
goal list like
how do you want to build out the company
what what are the the other things that
you want to try to do in the future man
yeah so i mean just keep building up
this black ops thing you know
i've done i look at every summer like an
album so i've been i left the next four
years ago and you take
covet out i've had like four like
amazing albums that no one's ever done
as far as like
the pickup games so like one off season
is an album the guys i've worked out
with the guys have gotten better so
i want to have 15 more of those albums
you know i'm just getting started with
that
and then you know outside of basketball
i'm doing uh
i have an album coming out i'm like
producing the same speaking albums you
got an album coming out for sure
i'm super excited about that call
welcome to the grind remember jock jams
back yeah so it's gonna be like the
hip-hop
jock jams it's gonna be you know music
that you can work out to
um i wanted to be like the theme music
for all hoopers
i got you know a little baby on it dirk
uh
meek fab travis
uh you gotta travis scott on the album
yeah trey songz
jesus christ you know that there's a did
you have to pay
boogie did you have to pay any of these
people uh yeah so i'm in like the
process of that but i'm doing it
independently
um the artist is going to be able to
keep ownership of this i was going to
ask you like
with those like do they do it and then
you got to like they do it on the
strength
of the honest truth it's actually been
the biggest stress of my life
in the last few months so i'm so cool
with all these artists that you know
will go to the studio to make the song
right here
and then then you got to deal with the
rest the label the business the
management the label
i got all the songs it's just the labels
these labels they don't respect me i'm
basketball i'm a basketball trainer
so you know just waiting on these these
people at the labels to
sign off on it to give the clearances to
you know
it's just a headache man but it's going
to be fire the albums
that's a hell of a that's a dj khaled
what i'm trying esque do i'm gonna do it
that's crazy he said travis scott
ain't nobody getting no travis scott
features out here [ __ ]
that's why what about cole so you know
it's funny that's the one guy
that uh i reached out to about it and
he's uh he's an album mode
right so he's like you know he wants the
next music that he drops he wants it to
be
his [ __ ] yeah so i understood that i
understood that is he still
actively training with you uh yeah yeah
we're still
training i go to north carolina uh like
a week so
not as much obviously as like a regular
offseason but
he's still training and he's you know
getting his album done
do you think he do you think he like he
has a serious chance to make an nba
roster
i don't know if he keeps improving
there's a chance for sure
at least maybe a summer league roster
yeah for sure summer league for sure